three two one go hey guys doing fine
okay
faster faster man you don't have
anything in your pockets do you no good
I don't know
NYX I forgot about that Oh doing good
doing good okay
hi okay it's starting to come together
alright you gotta see some grier at 30
seconds yeah that that finger speed look
at that speed he's doing good doing good
closing in on a minute though if we were
in a minute and you were tossed in you'd
be in I'd be in right now yeah you
would've been in this hey we're not
doing a minute right yeah he's almost
got it
don't mess up almost time okay
alright he did it a minute 27 he did it
yeah yeah the only one who's gonna be
able to do it and he did so I don't I
don't know these out how to do I've
never solved a Rubik's you can go oh I'm
going don't just fly flail will you
gotta look like if you look dog I'm done
try and turn it back to how it was okay
oh no it's still nice to come home I
think this is like this is reverse what
he's supposed to do okay I'm officially
messed it up yeah you've messed up I
woke up this morning and the first thing
I aim at going high flying on a red-eye
flight in the middle of the night and
then I I'm exhausted and I wake up and
I'm just going straight in the pool yeah
exactly man you got to hurry up you got
to get finger speed up because I don't
were running it doesn't matter if I get
my finger speed I'm not gonna be able to
solve it what you messed it up to get it
back to where it was before understand
do it better
Oh stand the way the other cabin huh how
about this this Shover here's a good
shot hi Chuck
come on what if I actually solved this
the last second I'm just gonna rest my
hand on your shoulder
that just as friends you know forget her
no problem man there's no point in me
doing I'm not gonna solve it slightly
just so what's your it's an excuse for
you to go into the pool just try man
you've still got time left because it is
a puzzle at the end of the day it is a
puzzle yeah it is puzzling it's random
it's just what's not raining okay it's
not runtime try just try really hard
yeah a little bit time left my cube
whooshing oh god it's cool oh my god Oh
got it wow that's weird cold okay well
now now that I got all my laughs out I
realized that it's my turn Oh ready two
one go oh jeez
but you didn't see you didn't backwards
solvent than your memorizing it did it
backwards if I was that smart I would
not be doing YouTube for a living
I'd be contributing to society somewhere
another oh geez says the engineer I'm
not an idiot graduated no boys worked as
an engineer for two years
it was like internship Oh God this is
not going from you guys
oh jeez ELISA Laurie shut off your time
uh uh don't put your hand on his your
money it's psychologically jarring oh
god I can't go anywhere from here
shouldn't go we don't have enough money
veggies Davis I'm Dwayne are you are you
are you looking at the time god oh god
oh god oh god oh god
Omar I don't know what to do they knew
they knew you're trying to solve the
Rubik's Cube so much crisis oh oh oh oh
you buddy Oh God oh now the wind started
blowing - so much colder than yeah it's
cold it's freezing bomb
okay thank you everybody so much for
watching we're back in LA officially
we're gonna have a lot of fun recording
some cool stuff we might even do some
more stuff please spider-man outfits
congratulations Ryan once again for
winning thank you regular shot right
being freezing hey I'm just gonna stand
over here yeah so thank you everybody
again for watching and as always
bye-bye-bye